let's talk a little bit about ion dipole
forces and before we think about how
ions and dipoles might interact let's
just remind ourselves what the
difference is between ions and dipoles
and i encourage you to pause this video
and try to refresh your own memory
before we refresh our memories together
all right now let's first think about
ions ions are atoms or molecules that
have a net charge so for example when
chlorine gains an electron and becomes
the chloride ion it's an ion because it
now has a net negative charge
similarly when sodium loses an electron
it now has a net positive charge so this
is the sodium ion
now what's the difference that in a
dipole
well generally speaking when we're
talking about dipoles we're not talking
about something that has necessarily a
net charge we're talking about something
where the charge is separated on
different ends of the molecule then you
have a partially positive end and you
have a partial negative end that there
is a molecular dipole moment and a good
example of a molecule that is a dipole
or has a dipole moment at a molecular
level is water water is a very polar
molecule we've talked about this many
times you have your oxygen which is
quite electronegative covalently bonded
to two hydrogens and those are really
polar covalent bonds because the
oxygen's so much more electronegative
that it hogs the electrons it's selfish
of the electrons and since the electrons
spend more time around the oxygen than
around the hydrogen you have a partial
negative charge at this end of the
molecule and you have partial positive
charges at the other end of the
molecules
and we described this when we talked
about hydrogen bonding where the partial
negative end of one water molecule would
be attracted to the partial positive end
of another water molecule but as we
talked about hydrogen bonds which are an
intermolecular force are just a special
case of dipole-dipole forces things that
are able to form hydrogen bonds just
have a very strong dipole moment because
you have hydrogen bonded to an oxygen a
nitrogen a fluorine that is quite
electronegative
so now that we know the difference
between ions and dipoles how might they
interact
well you might guess coulomb forces are
at play the partial negative end of a
dipole would be attracted to a
positively charged ion and i have
pre-arranged these water molecules so
that you have the partial negative end
is facing towards this sodium positive
ion
and so what i'm drawing right over here
these are ion dipole forces
similarly if you have a chloride anion
or a negative ion well then the
partially positive ends of the dipoles
are going to be attracted and so water
might arrange itself
in this way where the partial positive
ends the ends with the hydrogen are
facing the chlorine
and this is one of the reasons why it's
so easy to dissolve sodium chloride to
dissolve table salt in water those ions
are able to separate and be attracted to
the water molecules which are polar
which have molecular dipoles
now if i were to ask you what's going to
dictate the strength of the ion dipole
forces think about that pause this video
and what do you think is going to matter
well as you can imagine these are
coulomb forces so the strength of the
charges matter so you're going to have a
stronger ion dipole force if you have
stronger charges on the ions so instead
of a
sodium with a positive 1 charge if you
had a calcium ion that had a positive 2
charge then the partially negative ends
of the water molecules would be even
more strongly attracted you would have
stronger ion-dipole forces
similarly if you have stronger dipole
moments that will also make the
ion-dipole forces stronger or vice versa
if you had a molecule that had a weaker
dipole moment you're not going to have
as strong ion-dipole forces
coulomb forces are inversely
proportional to the distance between the
charges so you're also going to have
stronger ion-dipole forces the closer
that these things get to each other but
to some degree that's true of a lot of
the intermolecular forces we talked
about because on some level they are all
coulomb forces